what actually happened I believe and
again I think this is a reasonable
reading of history is what actually
happened was nukes then prevented World
War III and they prevented World War III
through the game theory of mutually
assured destruction had nukes not
existed right there would have been no
reason why the cold war did not go hot
right and then they're and then you know
and the military planners at the time
right thought both on both sides thought
that there was going to be World War III
on the plains of Europe and they thought
there was going to be like 100 million
people dead right it was like the most
obvious thing in the world to happen
right and it's the dog that didn't bark
right like it may be like the best
single net thing that happened in the
entire 20th century is it like that
didn't happen yeah actually just at that
point you say a lot of really brilliant
things it it it hit me just as you were
saying it
I don't know why it hit me for the first
time but we got two Wars in this in a
span of like uh 20 years
like we could have kept getting more and
more world wars more and more ruthless
it actually you could have had a US
versus Russia War you could have
by the way you there's another
hypothetical scenario the other
hypothetical scenario is the Americans
got the bomb the Russians didn't
right and then America's the big dog and
then maybe America would have had the
capability to actually roll back the
Iron Curtain
right I don't know whether that would
have happened but like it's entirely
possible right and and and the act of
these people who have these moral
positions about because they could
forecast they could model they could
forecast the future of how this
technology get used made a horrific
mistake because they basically ensured
that the Aaron Curtin would continue for
50 years longer than it would have
otherwise okay and again like these are
counterfactuals I don't know that that's
what would have happened but like
[Music]
the decision to hand the bomb over was a
big decision
made by people who were very full of
themselves
yeah but so me as an American me as a
person that loves America I also wonder
if us was the only ones with the nuclear
weapons
uh that was the argument for Handy that
was the was uh the guys who the guys who
handed over the bomb that was actually
their moral argument yeah I would as
you'd probably not hand it over to I
would be careful about the regimes you
handed over to maybe you give it to like
the British or something
we're like
uh like a democratically elected
government well look there are people to
this day who think that those five did
the right thing because they created a
balance of Terror as opposed to the us
having just and by the way let me let me
balance of Terror let's tell the full
version that's such a sexy ring to it
okay so the full version of the story is
John Von Neumann is a hero of both yours
and mine the full version of the story
is he advocated for a first right so
when the U.S had the bomb and Russia did
not he advocated for he said we need to
strike them right now
strike Russia yeah
yes yes
because he said World War III is
inevitable
um he was very hardcore uh he his his
theory was
um his theory was World War III is
inevitable we're definitely going to
have a world war three the only way to
stop world war three is we have to take
them out right now and we have to take
them out right now before they get the
bomb because this is our last chance
now again like is this an example of
philosophers and politics I don't know
if that's in there or not but this is in
the standard box no but it is meaning
yeah this is on the other side so so
most of the case studies most of the
case studies in books like this are the
crazy people on the left yeah
um about Neumann is a story arguably of
the crazy people on the right
um yeah stick to Computing John well
this is the thing and this is this is
the general principle getting push back
to our core thing which is like I don't
know whether any of these people should
be making any of these calls yeah
because there's nothing in either Von
Neumann's background or oppenheimer's
background or any of these people's
background that qualifies them as moral
authorities yeah well this actually
brings up the point of Nai who are the
good people to to reason about the
morality the ethics the outside of these
risks outside like the more complicated
stuff that you you agree on is you know
this will go into the hands of bad guys
and all the kinds of ways they'll do is
is interesting and dangerous
um is dangerous in interesting
unpredictable ways and who is the right
person who are the right kinds of people
to make decisions how to respond onto it
I just attack people so the history of
these fields this is what he talks about
in the book The History of these fields
is that the the competence and
capability and intelligence and training
and accomplishments of senior scientists
and technologists working on a
technology
and then being able to then make moral
judgments in the use of the technology
that track record is terrible
death record that track record is like
catastrophically bad
um and the people just illuminate the
people that developed that technology
are usually not going to be the right
people
well why would they so the claim is of
course they're the knowledgeable ones
but the problem is they've spent their
entire life in a lab right they're not
theologians but so what you find what
you find when you read when you read
this when you look at these histories
which you find is they generally are
very thinly informed on History yeah on
sociology on on on theology on morality
ethics they tend to manufacture their
own world views from scratch they tend
to be very sort of thin
um
they're not remotely the arguments that
you would be having if you got like a
group of Highly qualified theologians or
philosophers or you know um well let me
uh sort of uh as The Devil's Advocate
takes a sip of whiskey say that
I I agree with uh
with that but also it seems like the
people who are doing kind of the ethics
departments and these tax tech companies
go sometimes the other way yes
they're not nuanced on the on history or
theology or this kind of stuff they it
almost becomes a kind of uh outraged
activism towards
um
directions that don't seem to be yeah
grounded in history and humility and
Nuance it's again drenched with
arrogance so so definitely I'm not sure
which is worse oh no they're both bad
yeah so definitely not them either so
but I guess this is a hard yeah it's a
hard problem it's not a problem and this
goes back to where we started which is
okay who has the truth and it's like
well
um you know like how do Society survive
it like truth and how do we figure these
things out and like our elected leaders
play some role in it
you know we all play some role in it
um there have to be some set of public
intellectuals at some point that bring
you know rationality and judgment
humility to it yeah those people are few
and far between we should probably prize
them very highly yes celebrate humility
in our public leaders